un entretien exceptionnel donc avec vous
jean pierre elkabbach bienvenus 60 ans
présentait alors journaliste grand
interviewer politique
aujourd'hui vous officiez sur ces news
vous avez été patron d'europe 1 et donc
vous avez créé public sénat il y a vingt
ans c'est pour évoquer ce souvenir que
vous êtes avec nous ce soir
d'abord peut-être voir toutes ces images
toutes ses archives rassemblés par
cécile siksou et sylvia buissonneau
est-ce que ça suscite une émotion
particulière chez vous public sénat qui
a 20 ans une émotion oui en même temps
une joie et l'exaltation du moment du
début parce que ça a été une très très
longue bataille
d'abord entre nous entre nous et les
certains élus et puis avant la création
de la chaîne ya eu pendant dix ans des
présidents successifs qui ont essayé de
créer cette chaîne et qui n'y sont pas
parvenus parce qu'il y avait le grand
partage entre les deux assemblées
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat il
faut les trouver des créneaux qui soit
juste pour l'une et l'autre chaîne or à
l'époque il y avait toujours en fonction
des institutions le vème république yvon
que l'assemblée nationale a toujours le
dernier mot
l'assemblée voulait avoir davantage il
nous nous sommes battus ils vont le
valais du côté de lcn qui était le cds
allemand qui a été le premier
responsable et moi pour essayer de
trouver des créneaux qui soit juste pour
chacun d'entre nous et je constate qu'en
dehors de quelques ajustements
on vit toujours sur ce que nous avions
décidé il ya à peu près une vingtaine
d'années et qui privilégie d'une
certaine façon à mon avis dont j'allais
dire notre chaîne thierry shana public
cette année le dites pas trop fort alors
pourquoi ce nom public sénat et pourquoi
pas lcp sénat pour moi il ya une chaîne
aux états unis qui s'appelle sispann qui
a été créé par un journaliste qui n a eu
assez de travailler dans une télévision
de avec la publicité et qui avait servi
de modèle pour d'autres chaînes et puis
pour moi je suis allé les voir j'ai vu
comment il avait fonctionné et c'est
laurent fabius qui était le président je
lui rends hommage comme je rends hommage
à christian penser le président alain
méar son directeur de cabinet et le
sénateur jacques valade qui sont ceux
qui nous ont appuyés tout le temps
soutenus
la chaîne câblée sispann et laurent
fabius a voulu que la chaîne s'appelle
elle ces panels mais ça marchait pas se
disaient pas mais nous nous avons été
toujours opposé à cela
public sénat pourquoi est on l'avait
fait en concertation avec les sénateurs
comme toujours on les a associés au
travail que nous faisions parce que
c'est ma cité l'actionnaire ont été
responsables devant le bureau surtout la
gestion financière etc et budgétaires et
de l'autre côté je voulais bien montrer
que c'est une chaîne qui allie
s'adresser à tous les publics à tous les
français ce n'était pas une télévision
pour les familles des sénateurs eux dans
un premier temps il se demande
d'ailleurs pourquoi on était là qu'est
ce que l'on voulait
d'autant plus que contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent et nous avons
commencé la chaîne avec des journalistes
que j'ai recruté un intérêt ici un an et
on les a revus car à certains j'ai été
très heureux de retrouver d'un terrain
tarnos de retrouver pierre henri
gergonne là qui sont là et que je viens
sur la question des classes les jours et
comme vous avez bien mentionné à ceux
qui sont partis c'est à dire sonia
mabrouk à salamé qui que j'ai recruté
qui ont été formés ici pendant des
années comme rama yade qui a travaillé
ma balle avec nous donc voilà pourquoi
public sénat vous parliez des réticences
des sénateurs est ce que ça a été
compliqué de les convaincre d'introduire
des caméras dans les salles de
commissions pendant quelque temps je
dois dire oui on avait le soutien de
quelques-uns lambert qui était alain
lambert qui était le président de la
commission des finances qui nous
soutenaient jean pierre bel qui a fini
par accepter avec didier guillaume le
vice président devenu vice président et
quelques mots mais il y avait une sorte
de résistance demande à quoi ça sert
qu'est-ce qu'on allait montrer mais ils
se sont rendu compte que l'on faisait
des portraits que on était intéressé par
le travail qu'il faisait ici que l'ont
montré les commissions d'enquêté j'y
reviendrai et puis sinon ce qui a été
déterminant
c'était le bout de trois quatre ans le
numérique
parce que tout de suite nous avons
décidé de candidater pour avoir notre
place un canal un canard et nous avons
eu le canal 13 que depuis beaucoup de
gens nous nous envient vous à bien vous
faire ressortir pour m pour ce matin et
13 et il ya eu des résistances et à
partir de là les sénateurs les élus ont
vu que l'on parlait de canton les cités
quand on faisait des portraits d'eux en
les intégrant dans leurs
circonscriptions leur dire vous avez la
télé et comme il savait qu'il était
invité
nulle part ailleurs que là ils ont
compris l'importance du de la chaîne il
faut dire que pourquoi ça a été
difficile parce que c'est un canal avec
deux télévisions qui peuvent être
concurrentes quelquefois mais qui sont
complémentaires et que nous avons chaque
fois essayer d'harmoniser dans le
travail quand il était important et
jamais de problème d'indépendance
éditoriale de pression la part des élus
sur le contenu de la chaîne déprogramme
ça je peux dire non parce que c'était un
principe d'accord avec le président
poncelet j'ai fait adopter le principe
irrévocable de l'indépendance que ce
n'était pas une télévision chargé de la
communication du sénat mais que c'était
une source d'information pour les
français et à partir de là ils m'ont
donné une indépendance et je reconnais
qu'ils ont toujours accepté parce que je
m'aime pour le recrutement des
journalistes je pouvais pas recruter d
où je n'ai pas pu recruter des
journalistes qui auraient dit on vient
pas faire la communication
il fallait qu'ils aient la carte de
presse et c'est sa facilité les choses
et je donne un exemple quand il y avait
des gens qui protestaient contre telle
ou telle émission où entre moi et ils
s'adressaient directement à christian
penser à l'emea et ils me renvoyaient
les lettres en me disant c'est à vous
dépendez y disait ça nous regarde pas
c'est lui et les meilleurs prix
indépendant et on lui règlera son compte
au bout de trois ans où on renouvellera
son mandat alors à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire jean pierre elkabbach nous
avons interviewé gérard larcher l'actuel
président du sénat il est revenu lui
aussi sur les débuts mais aussi sur la
fonction est l'utilité de la chaîne et
puis il a eu un petit
pour l'écouter j'étais vice-président du
sénat jeune vice président du cdh a au
moment où la loi de décembre 1999 a créé
le principe des chaînes parlementaires
j'ai donc participé à la préparation de
ce projet autour quelque chose qui est
semble-t-il encore tout à fait important
faire mieux connaître le parlement avoir
une pédagogie et on voit encore le
déficit et c'est le rôle de la chaîne
parlementaire public sénat
le lien avec les territoires et on voit
que le lien avec la presse quotidienne
ou hebdo régional est quelque chose de
fort qui aujourd'hui s'est développée et
je me réjouis vraiment et puis peut-être
une dimension de réaffirmer le
bicamérisme depuis la réforme du
quinquennat le bicamérisme pas ré
exploser notamment en faveur du sénat
mais je crois que donc je souhaite
vraiment et puis j'ai quand même la
pensée pour trois présidents jean pierre
elkabbach le fondateur qui a vraiment
construit ensuite gilles leclair et
emmanuel kessler le président
d'aujourd'hui donc quand on fête un
anniversaire on veut pas vrai
rétrospective mais on se dit que ça a
été construit par des femmes et des
hommes dans la diversité des équipes
essaient à tout cela que je prends ce
dont vous donc jean pierre elkabbach
c'est reconnaître essentielle vient dire
le le président gérard gachet parce
qu'en plus c'était notre obsession de
défendre les deux assemblées de défendre
même temps la démocratie parlementaire
en données et de donner la parole au
sénat et en plus je vais le dire tout de
suite j'ai toujours été contre la fusion
des deux chaînes chaque fois qu'il y à
une nouvelle législature une nouvelle
majorité à l'assemblée nationale les
députés ont de l'appétit de la
gourmandise ils ont envie d'avoir une
seule chaîne est en réalité c'était
assez hypocrite parce qu'une seule
chaîne c'est leur donne l avantage est
donc de nier la deuxième chaîne je veux
rappeler tout à l'heure parce que
l'assemblée nationale a le dernier mot
et les présidents que ce soit poncelet
et larcher se sont toujours battus pour
ne pas céder
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
l'horizon médiatique est complètement
différent s'en rend pas compte
quand nous avons commencé il ya vingt
ans il n'y avait pas de portable
il n'y avait pas de numérique il n'y
avait pas de la chaîne d'information
continue
public sénat c'était vraiment une
innovation on va maintenant écouter
l'ancien président du sénat que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure christian
poncelet qui nous a donc quitté en
septembre dernier à l'occasion des 10
ans cette fois il avait lui aussi
rappelé l'importance des chaînes
parlementaires écoutez j'ai été élu en
septembre 1998
j'ai trouvé sur le tage air de mon
bureau un dossier marqué télévision
chaînes parlementaires
je me suis dit de quoi s'agit-il je par
conséquent j'ai compris en la lecture de
ce dossier qu'il fallait du bon sens de
la réflexion et sur toute la volonté et
ne pas craindre d'affronter
l'impopularité ce qui doit être la
noblesse de l'élu dès l'instant où il
s'agit de défendre une cause juste
intéressant si je suis en train de le
retrouver
parce qu'il s'est battu avec l'air de
rien il s'est battu il a imposé la
chaîne et il a fait preuve à la fois de
volonté et de beaucoup de courage
indispensable la création de ces chaînes
parlementaires avec 20 ans de recul pour
la démocratie pour la visibilité des
élus est ce que c'est pas même encore
plus important aujourd'hui qu'il ay
parce que le climat est en même temps
l'horizon complètement changé
aujourd'hui vous avez le numérique
vous avez les ipad les et les phones
vous avez tous les éléments vous allez
avoir bientôt la 5g vous allez avoir
tout ce que les plateformes tout ce qui
change et ça veut dire que c'est
nécessaire mais on le dira peut-être
tout à l'heure pour le développement et
la survie de la chaîne il ya intérêt à
beaucoup bouger et inventer mais tout
doit se faire avec la concertation des
sénateurs et emmanuel kessler a de la
chance et je le salue d'ailleurs parce
que lui il a cette fois des sénateurs
qui ont compris l'intérêt la jeanne et
qu'ils ne peuvent que soutenir les
équipes actuelles alors très vite vous
allez créer des moments forts de
télévision avec des retransmissions en
direct je pense notamment la
retransmission des auditions de la
commission stasi qui n'était pas une
commission parlementaire
je rappelle à nos téléspectateurs de
quoi il s'agissait en quelques mots 3
juillet 2003 jacques chirac créé une
commission de réflexion sur
l'application du principe de laïcité
dans la république c'est bernard stasi
qui la préside il est alors médiateur de
la république pendant trois mois
la commission va auditionner près de 150
personnes de la société civile des
partis politiques et des instances
religieuses et ce que peut nous raconter
comment c'est arrivé à l'antenne de
public l'allemand quand
nous avons entendu que le président
jacques chirac voulait cette commission
sur la laïcité et des chats sur
l'interdiction pas des ports de port des
signes religieux à l'école déjà oui la
laïcité
je suis allé voir bernard stasi et je
lui dis voilà nous la chaîne
parlementaire on peut vous ouvrir les
antennes et vous laisser autant que vous
voulez vous les 10 heures 15 heures et
puis nous ça nous arrangeait l'ipad sous
à l'époque on pouvait pas acheter du
programme et pas de publicité donc et il
m'a dit oui mais tf1 et france 2 veut
lh2 diffusé jeudi ben on verra au
dernier moment et au dernier moment
les deux autres chaînes ou la présidence
je sais pas dire sont dégonflés mais on
dit on peut pas et donc à ce moment là
le président poncelet a accepté avec les
sénateurs que nous ayons ici et salle
clémenceau et les salles médicis quand
les équipes ont caméra et nous avons pu
faire les retransmis dans les
commissions la commission stasi 65
heures de programmes les lundi mercredi
vendredi matin avec tout un monde qui a
défilé dans les premiers temps ça
n'intéressait personne comme d'habitude
et puis un jour sont venues témoigner
des médecins des infirmières qui disait
à l'hôpital on ne peut plus passer à
quelques barbus qui empêchent leurs
femmes de venir accoucher qui menace
et puis d'un seul coup les gens ont pris
conscience de ce qu'était c'était là la
commission stasi
il y avait un jeune rapporteur avec le
rapporteur principal qui était un grand
juriste remich mars et ce grand ce
rapporteur adjoint vous avez des idées
laurent wauquiez oui il veut lui manger
des sandwichs avec nous à l'époque ils
étaient tous gentils
bon bref et mais il ya eu la commission
outreau il ya justement ce que là ce
n'était pas une commission parlementaire
à proprement parler on vient la loi on
fait avec les deux chaînes personnes
pouvaient rivaliser avec nous et donc on
a eu du succès ce que vous alliez une
libre diffusion totale etc
il ya eu la commission outreau toutes
les façons mais ce que je veux dire
j'avais passé des accords avec des
chaînes américaines 6,6 panne qui nous
prévenait quand il y avait
des moments importants et je me souviens
de la diffusion par exemple c'était le
procès des tortionnaires américains les
soldats larribe la prison et on voyait
défiler les le ministre de la défense je
crois que c'était mcnamara puis les
généraux tout en uniforme on l'avait
diffusée en direct et les gens avaient
tellement appelé qu'on la rediffuser une
deuxième fois donc il y avait les
commissions fait même aux états unis par
exemple en ce moment en ce moment moi
j'aurais diffuser ce qui est en train de
se passer au congrès américain il y à
l'audition de la candidate au poste de
juge suprême des etats unis c'est un
grand problème pour elle et pour nous
parce qu'on va savoir ce que ils
décideront sur la contraception les
droits des femmes l'avortement et ses
dires il y avait ça puis en même temps
avec les accords avec les nations unies
kofi annan que je connaissais bien et
est devenu un ami y compris de de la
chaîne public sénat et donc ont été
alertés on pouvait faire perrine
tarneaud me rappeler qu'elle est on
avait fait des duplex et des directs et
elle-même du du de l'immeuble des
nations unies à new york
on s'est intéressés public français sa
forme est et on a montré qu'en théorie
les débats le premier débat entre
schroeder et angela merkel qui a ramené
la victoire de merkel berlusconi ont
montré les débats et on les regarde en
un jour nous avons entendu claude
bartolone qui sortait d'une réunion du
parti socialiste ils disent y'en a marre
on s'engueule des états il faut qu'un
jour on se met tous ensemble et j'étais
avec quelqu'un que je veux saluer
qu'isabelle rémi thomas faisait ski qui
avec un à marco wittmann collaboratrice
avec anne-marie mots qui travaillaient
avec moi à l'époque nous nous sommes dit
mais pourquoi on leur donnerait pas la
possibilité pas le jour même on leur
envoie des lettres à l'époque jacques
lang qui pensait être candidat a écrit
oui sous la crosse kahn laurent fabius
le seul qui a attendu un moment c'était
françois hollande
il devait avoir des problèmes à régler
avec celle qui est devenue ensuite la
candidate qui laissait gaulle
rien et donc c'est sur les primaires qui
ont été diffusées sur cette chaîne ça a
été un événement parce que même les
sénateurs on est mais c'est pas possible
new york times en eut montré les photos
de le public sénat dans le seul à vous
êtes en train de nous un prix mais on
voit les images et les plombs la
naissance des primaires socialistes
autre moment très fort de l'histoire
sénat c'étaient les premières qu'on a
des niveaux si avec des trois candidats
donc on l'est on les a vu laurent fabius
dominique strauss-kahn ségolène royal
trois débats tous animé par emilie aubry
que l'on voit là mais emmanuel kessler
colons actuelle et ont préparé les
questions semblent pour être plus
efficace et pour être digne de frein de
l'honneur et de la vente âge qu'on avait
parce qu'on savait qu'on est des cartes
et des moments de tension aussi en
coulisses j'imagine des candidats qui se
regardaient ou qui se jaugeaient comment
vous avez vécu cela parce que tout se
passer j'imagine haut soit en régie soit
en loge maquillage je vois si le conflit
dure et oui bien sûr parce qu'elle m'a
desservi pendant un bout de temps
il y avait le au 1er étage 3 chacun
avait sa loge et jallet saluer chacun
ségolène royal et ses collaborateurs
intel intel et un moment une
collaboratrice de ségolène aurait elle
pu sortir de la loge de fabius elle est
allé lui dire il a choisi oufa bus ou
strauss kahn contre euro et depuis
ségolène royal est sûre et certaine que
j'étais contre elle elle a eu tort mais
peut-être qu'avec le temps les choses
s'arrangeront faisait puis elle m'a
jamais crue donc s'arrêter comme une
sorte d'amertume
et comme elle est rancunière ça doit
durer mais c'était simplement un petit
incident j'ai raison de la réaction des
sénateurs face à ce genre d'évènements
que vous diffusiez il n'était pas gêné
que ce soit pas le travail parlementaire
à proprement parler que vous diffusiez
selon la cds - sujet non parce que
c'était deux c'était des moments
politiques
au début quand on disait au début avant
le numérique et c'est vrai ils ont été
d'abord quelle surprise quelques amants
ont protesté contre moi pourquoi parce
qu'on avait je me souviens retransmis en
direct tout le congrès de la cfdt
puis le congrès du parti socialiste on
était venu me dire et on est à dire au
président de la chaîne qu'est ce que
c'est ces décos schiste qui prennent le
pouvoir et on leur a dit mais accepte et
l'impartialité et l'indépendance de la
chaîne et on leur a dit mais le medef
s'est elle jours et c'est d'accord mais
le parti du dr ump chez plus qu'on sait
qu'ils vont toujours été respectée
d'enquêté et coop
on leur a démontré qu'avec ses
équilibres ce qu'on voit là quand même
avec toutes ces diffusions d'événements
très fort en direct c'est finalement que
les chaînes parlementaires et en
particulier public sénat ou presque
inspiré ce qui se fait aujourd'hui c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les chaînes d'information
continue le faut aussi diffuser des
débats entre candidats des événements
politiques des meetings des rencontres
des primaires finalement vous l'avez
fait avec
avec plus de moyens ils l'ont fait et
dans certains cas ils se sont imposés
plus ou moins de biens même bien et ils
sont à peu près présent ce qui entraîne
avec ce que j ai tout à l'heure d'où la
nécessité de ne pas nous copier ce qui
nous copie enfin le nouveau public sénat
vous imitent aujourd'hui la clinique et
qui vous imitent et qu'ils ont compris
que là il y avait de la matière mais
comme ce sont des chaînes qui
retransmettent surtout l'intérieur les
petits problèmes intérieurs le cocorico
nationale ça l'est peut-être une
possibilité de trouver des des domaines
et des thèmes qui intéressent les
français et qui sont ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis avec 30 qu'on aurait pu faire
le feuilleton en train en or en excite
schröder
le bauxite etc à voir cette dimension
sans négliger les problèmes français
mans peut plus se contenter à faire ce
que public sénat faisait au début et qui
est de l'ordre archaïque du elle avait
un temps d'avancé du début je dis c'est
un peu moi c'est vous qui les 30 jours
pour tenir viendra vous avez aussi
introduit des moments de culture sur
public sénat je pense évidemment à
bibliothèque médicis l'émission vous
animiez en personne à l'antenne dès 2001
de grands noms sont passés sur ce
plateau c'est si les veines et sylvia
buissonneau là encore ont sélectionné
une archive on la regarde ensemble et on
la commente après pensez pas que je
pourrais être le cercle des res est une
roche qui était très cher alors je me
suis dit si ça vient je veux l'acheter
mais la chose que j'ai pas dit encore et
que c'est une broche française et là
vous avez une broche au sénat c'est un
havre de la vie et je porte ça parce que
je suis un optimiste
il paraît que selon la broche il faut
traduire à la fois votre humeur et
l'humeur du moment mais ça commençait
comme enjeu parce que à saddam hussein
la paix leur forme et j'avais un
reproche de serpents et je ne portais
une journée pendant les débats sur irak
à l'onu et télé me demande qu'est-ce que
pourquoi vous porter cette broche et
jeudi parce qu'il m'a appelé un serpent
voilà on a reconnu madeleine albright
première femme à avoir occupé le poste
de secrétaire proches aux états unis
bill clinton elle a été son ministre et
puis ça ministre et ensuite de deux
obama parlera qu'obama s'était éteint si
nicole américaine la démocrate mais eu
beaucoup plus de gens d'un spectateur
kofi annan des chefs d'état étrangers et
ces mêmes africains
est ce que je voulais dire c'est que
cette rémission bibliothèque médicis
on m'en parle encore aujourd'hui parce
que c'était une émission sur les livres
une émission qui a marqué les idées
positives ou même passionné de lecture
d'ailleurs et l'idée était née
comment aux etats-unis c'est-à-dire
d'eau et en visitant le studio de 6
panne j'ai vu que le créateur faisait
tous les dimanches une émission sur un
livre alors lui c'était un livre il ne
maquille est pas les gens qui venaient
ni lui et il fermer les rideaux son
style coup était tout à fait noir et
pendant une heure parler d'un livre j'ai
dit les français ne supportant pas qu'on
me fasse une interview donne donc j'ai
voulu ouvrir et là c'était un hommage à
la création littéraire et au débat
intellectuel dans toute sa diversité
et ce qui est formidable quand gym quand
je vois maintenant certains auteurs les
la slimani et beaucoup d'autres ils ont
fait leurs débuts ici c'est à dire quand
ils sont venus ils n'étaient pas du tout
connu et peu à peu ils ont imposé leur
talent qui a été reconnue c'est nous qui
les avions repéré et puis a lieu en même
temps
des thèmes qui sont aujourd'hui
familiers la décolonisation la
l'abolition de l'esclavagé avec olivier
grenouilleau le grand spécialiste
français et le musicien jordi savall qui
avait combattu il y a eu l'intelligence
artificielle les robots l'avenir de la
planète tout le télétravail public sénat
et médiathèques médicis ont été d'une
certaine façon des pionniers où je dis
pas pour faire le mariole mais parce que
c'était ils sont des thèmes et je les
revois et ont laissé relançait on
anticipe à pied je suis heureux et
flatté que les plus grands historiens
français sont passés dans bibliothèque
mais ici sur les gens et des philosophes
je peux citer je peux citer patrick
boucheron michel winoc emmanuel de
varices qu'elle qui va travailler avec
moi sur ses news les philosophes marcel
conche lucien jerphagnon celui un grand
spécialiste saint-augustin qui avait
écrit un petit livre que je vous
recommande et qui s'appelait c'est
toujours mieux avant et il racontait que
depuis cicéron et sénèque
on disait dans des textes c'était mieux
avant donc il dit ça suffit de dire ça
c'est pourquoi moi je vis et sera
peut-être mieux après il vaut mieux il
vaut mieux justement ils sont des gens
qui donc sont venus et qui on rapportait
beaucoup téléspectateurs donc qu'ils se
souviennent de tel ou tel parfois moi je
les ai oubliés qui se souviennent et
jerphagnon disait une manière assez
familière le soir je dis à ma femme
comment je vais faire pour être moins
con demain et c'était un grand
philosophe ou un grand historien
avant de se quitter jean pierre
elkabbach on va se projeter un petit peu
sur l'avenir alors vous avez un tout
petit peu commencé mais on va aller on
va aller plus loin c'est principe de
l'émission public sénat 20 ans que
peut-on lui souhaiter là aussi on a posé
cette question à gérard larcher en
écoute
public sénat c'est d'abord faire mieux
qu'on peut l'être mieux comprendre le
parlement c'est aussi faire que les
territoires soient plus en relation avec
la décision et parlementaires et qu'on
entend le plus la voix des territoires
luxe et da c'est aussi le bicamérisme
c'est pour ça que c'est pas par espèce
de peur mais je crois profondément qu'il
est utile d'avoir une indépendance à la
fois éditorial mais une autonomie de
chercheurs du parlement gérard larcher
qui aimeraient qu'on entende encore plus
la voix des territoires sur public sénat
l'avenir ces lanières l on voyait les
ferries ont d'abord l'engagement
personnel solennelle institutionnelle du
président du sénat gérard larcher
c'est une garantie de longévité pour la
chaîne il ya des initiatives qui était
dans le passé ou bibliothèque médicis
qui depuis n'a pas été remplacé ce assez
on peut dire le passé de la chaîne mais
ce que je veux dire oui en tant que
fondateur vous avez la gentillesse de le
dire et puis qu'il est animé pendant une
dizaine d'années avec quelqu'un auquel
je rends hommage qui étaient gelés dit
tout à l'heure mais je me répétais il
fallait peut-être oded rémi tomaszewski
c'était un duo et j'ai beaucoup de
souvenirs c'est une jolie nostalgie
c'est le travail que nous avons fait
tous les deux sens et dans le climat oui
et je dirais oui en tant que fondateur
je souhaite à public sénat
une longue vie elle aura mais à mon avis
il faut qu'elles évoluent parce que la
routine c'est mortel quand j'ai dit il
faut qu'elle évolue à l'époque c'était
très originale de créer une chaîne de
cette nature de ces sorts etc
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible il est
indispensable de réinventer cette
télévision et je veux dire et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure depuis et
public sénat a été imité mais maintenant
elle a gelé dit le numérique les
plateformes et ses envies tout les
enfants quand il faut donc qu'elle
trouve comment dire sans cesse ce
qu'elles doivent sans cesse trouver de
nouveaux accords de nouvelles idées de
nouvelles initiatives de nouvelles
formes
qu'elle sache surprendre qu'elle sache à
mon avis un innover sans cesse être en
mouvement dans l'intérêt du sénat du
public les territoires des territoires
du parlement de la république est
aujourd'hui tellement malmené et en même
temps de la démocratie et je veux le
dire pour moi ce sont pas des grands
bourg je dirais c'est presse la chair
vivante de la liberté et c'est pour ça
que je dirais même en me paraphrasant
quelquefois il faut de l'audace
donc comme je le disais tout à l'heure
j'ai relâché et christian poncelet du
courage il quelles que soient les
risques il faut innover il faut de
l'audace et pas avoir peur de son ombre
et donc il faut innover et je dirais de
la créativité
voilà créé stimulant jeu des classes
mais encore une fois pour oser
sinon on s'enferme et la chaîne peut
être menacée alors qu'elle l'a et
qu'elle doit avoir avec toutes ces
équipes actuelles et futures
un grand avenir il faut oser le message
est lancé merci infiniment jean pierre
elkabbach merci d'avoir ouvert avec nous
cette séquence anniversaire des 20 ans
rendre hommage à cette télévision qui
est très très importante et qui doit
comme on l'a dit avoir un bel avenir et
on y travaille beaucoup et avec vigueur
et rigueur tous les jours merci
infiniment une séquence qui va se
poursuivre en demain je vous le rappelle
à 20h30
lcp public sénat qui vous propose une
soirée exceptionnelle avec un
documentaire inédit enquête au parlement
de stéphane haumant avec première ligne
voilà je crois que j'ai tout dit fin de
cette émission se retrouvent donc demain
en direct à 18h en attendant vous
retrouvez bonjour chez vous au
rayonnement de chine y reçoit demain
matin julien bayou secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie souhaite une
excellente soirée so
[Musique]